the Seattle International Comedy
Competition get up for miles
[Applause]
thank you I'll be funny
don't worry about it you don't have to
be funny to parties
people are like prawns I'm gonna kick
your ass
oh my good that's the best place to be
kicked
and soft there's nothing important back
there
we're trying to fight you thinking about
watching the UFC
I think they should introduce a new
submission in the UFC where if you can
hold down your opponent and pretend to
have butt sex with them for 10 seconds
not only do win the fight for your
opponent now he has to retire if you're
in a real fight and you can still knock
your opponent out nobody's gonna
remember that you knocked your phone
they're gonna you're probably not to
move
I think about this a lot I love
Brazilian Jujitsu Brazilian Jujitsu is
like normal jiu-jitsu except you try to
feature opponents by ripping their pubic
hair off it helps if you're a girl
a lot of Terrence I love I love sports
my sister thought that LA Fitness was a
Mexican Jew because she thought it was
pronounced LA Fitness
welcome to the fitness workout on
pinatas treadmills have a lot more
handles this profession I love watching
basketball
I was watching basketball with my
European friends and they were like man
I can't even watch this there's too much
scoring it felt so bad for them their
poor brain is shriveled from watching
soccer on their life they can handle the
stimulation of a game that's designed to
be watchable I tried watching soccer
they didn't score for so long I thought
the ball went out of Bounce when they
scored they caught the net was there
caught the ball I'm a huge nerd I'm a
bandwagon fan of all the best sports
teams and people get mad at me I'm just
like hey I'm trying to enjoy your stupid
hobby
I'm pretty good at cheering what my team
does something right I hit it out of the
park as you guys say I'm sorry I didn't
want to waste my life watching people
suck at things I hate it when people
tell me how I'm autistic that just makes
you want to break eye contact with you
and hum a song
finally I might be autistic but you're
the one going around bars diagnosing
strangers with diseases
maybe you're autistic I've never been
like hey bro do you mesothelioma you
talk like you have mesothelioma
I'm a polite person I don't understand
when I meet someone the first thing that
they'll tell me is their name I'm
supposed to remember your name for this
entire conversation on the off chance
that I ever want to see you again seems
inefficient why don't you tell me your
name at the end so I know who I blame
for this shitty chit chat I have John is
responsible judging by that joke a lot
of people like man I'm not book-smart
I'm street smart oh you're smart in a
way that's not measurable or
economically I can be it for you maybe
you're not smart maybe they're kind of
dumb and you're insecure about it that's
how you punch me in the face
it's not smart that's called battery it
hurts I don't I don't like talking to
people very much I like the Internet
battery I've got two internet arguments
a lot have you ever gone into an
Internet argument man I'm really glad I
did that today well he learned a lot
from a fellow scholar I learned on the
internet that people who make logical
fallacies are not the same people who
care when you point it out it's a very
small bed diagram
i-i-i don't have a easy time talking to
people standing outside I was like man
it's getting kind of cold here and this
guy was like oh man this is nothing in
Chicago it gets so much colder I was
like oh yeah I guess it is pretty warm
now that you mentioned you're from
Chicago said something earlier I was
freezing my ass off
I wonder what happens if you talk to
that guy from Alaska if I was deaf I
would hate to see Italian people talking
a chair a table cow what the [ __ ] keep
your hands double I love living in the
northwest
I love the Northwest because the weather
gives me an excuse to be lazy every day
it's like why should I try what the
day's not even trying
well this jerk off of watch Netflix
I took the Lord attended I think it's
weird that vegans are a thing if you
don't know what vegans are those are
people who ruin your dinner plans and
that they're really proud that they
ruined your dinner plans
I think vegans are guilty of a crime way
worse than the murder of animals and
that's a crime of annoying a human
if I can get my vegans friends to shut
up during dinner I wouldn't keep two
koala bears what's the point of having
the healthiest body in the world if your
personality makes people want to punch
her in the face where's your quinoa now
my my friend has a peanut allergy which
is a bath most people but he has one of
the worst symptoms which is where you
can't shut the [ __ ] up about it
it's a debilitating condition because
you're annoyed people ain't giving them
a way to kill you I like to smoke
marijuana I also live with my mom but
that's completely
nothing to do with each other I came
home hi one day my mom was like Hans why
are your eyes so red I was like oh I was
just crying she's like really why are
you crying oh my god I just got into a
fight with my girlfriend she's like I
don't know you got a girlfriend why
don't you tell me I was like oh that's
just her kid it started school it was a
bad time she's like she's a kid oh my
god [ __ ] it all right it's much easier
to admit a drug hammer than my emotions
I like to walk my dog when I'm high but
people I could really weird around dogs
like this one lady comes up to my dog
and she's like oh how old are you I was
like oh I'm a dog or not a ventriloquist
and then she try to pet my dog like this
and she like inched her way forward and
my dog barked at her and she was like oh
he could smell my fear I was like no
he's gonna smile fear he could see you
being a weirdo we can all see you I
don't understand the garbage disposal in
my house who was like hey you know that
light switch that people use every day
without thinking about it yeah why don't
we have that turn on a knife tornado
that'll surely not cause any heart
attacks
it was like why don't you make it a
different button or something there's
like a switch in my house that turns on
a chainsaw my sister just got back from
a mission trip if you don't know what a
mission trip is that's what Americans go
to third-world countries to get new
profile pictures she had a good photo
shoot share the WWJD bracelet on her
wrist which stands for what would Jesus
do but I very rarely see her behaving
like a Jewish carpenter don't look her
house he's watching she came back and
she was like monsters you know that your
toilet water is cleaner than the
drinking water in third-world countries
I'm not guilt-trip me I'm not like
peeing in Africa water let go or the
airport and taking a [ __ ] in it you know
this is just the water I get what do you
want me to do
let me see if I see an African walking
on the street I'll let him drink from my
toilet it's not a problem
just just flush
my name is hans kim that's my real name
[Applause]
are you guys australian han scam is a
real name it's not a stage name
i was like how do i get audiences think
about North Korea and the Nazis a lot of
confirmed comedy that's my real name
it's over parents named me my parents
named me Hans because they didn't want
kids at school to make fun of me for
having an Asian dude so they gave me a
German one and said
work like a charm there's no idea I was
a usual
their plan great a challenge my friends
at school but they would say things that
hurt my feelings they wouldn't even
realize that my friends would be like
hey Hans you got such an Asian smile
like oh thanks now I get to think about
how I'm physically different from
everyone around me every time I feel
happiness my friend I had a white friend
named Tanner which I thought was kind of
funny Tanner than what they should be
like hey this is my Mexican friend
Tanner
that's my black for tennis that's not
racist just as suffixes I am Asian or as
I've known this country I'm Chinese
I'm from a Province in China called
South korea-japan province at the Asians
deserve more respect in this country cuz
our first job was to build railroads and
now no one's even using that [ __ ]
anymore you ever wonder why we're so bad
at driving we're all on the railroad
this is your fault guy loves racism
we all have our hobbies I love being
Asian because whenever some is racist to
me I know that they're crazy like what
you hate respectful people who keep to
themselves
okay good luck finding an affordable car
a lot of people don't know the
difference between Asians there's
Chinese Japanese and Korean those are
the East Asians Chinese people they'll
try to cheat you out of money they're
very conniving Japanese people they're
very arrogant the light on Japanese I'm
better than you
Korean people were perfect in every way
I experienced racism earn a like I smoke
weed have the do i smoke weed a lot or
something but most people who races they
don't even know that their race is like
that guy
you just found that out today
like this one guy he just comes up to me
out of nowhere he says Tokyo typically
all this oil I was like dude you're so
racist just cuz I look like this as you
may speak your ching chong language
don't be racist and the post office is
right there this one guy he comes out to
me and he says hey Hans I heard in Asia
you could beat your wife I was like oh
that's good to know because in America
she's kicking my ass she's a tough lady
I love white people I think having white
pride is good like be proud of your race
is good but I think a lot of people with
white pride do it wrong
they're always into the Nazis and the
Confederate flag they're never into
building a castle and yodeling why
aren't you wearing a kilt
I I think like a better a flag is very
offensive because I feel like that flag
would be like if a man went up to his
wife and he was like hey honey
remember that time we're gonna do that
huge argument and I almost divorced you
I try to kill you yeah I'm really proud
of that time that's who I am as a person
that's why I got a divorce papers
tattooed on my chest I think they should
have a new confederate flag it could
just be a picture of a fat person
failing a test
[Applause]
the racists like that one I caught me by
surprise and I expect that I love being
Asian I don't understand people who are
like learning English should get out of
my country but then when they hear
broken English they get really mad at
you it's like this is your plan in
action I'm trying to learn you know it's
not like I'm doing this on purpose I'm
not trying to rep my hood by stuttering
and being flustered English is a hard
language to learn it's a class taught in
school can you imagine if you were a
judge for your algebra skills hey find X
we get out of my country it's hard to
date as an Asian man because there are a
lot of negative stereotypes about us
like yeah we have small dicks I'm just
saying it you guys have all heard it
right we're the only ones with negative
stereotypes about our genitals no one's
like oh you're from laughs yeah I heard
you had weird buttholes over there
Asians and dicks
even if even if my dick was small and
it's not it's pretty big but you because
it's not like we would hear that be like
oh we got small dicks okay we'll go find
a new hobby
see you guys we wouldn't just give up we
would start studying because that's what
we do know how to use that thing like a
sewing machine
my friends like just go to an Asian
massage parlor you can get a happy
ending I'm like well that's cool for you
guys but I'm just getting jerked off by
a lady who looks like my aunt it's even
better for me so yeah I'll do that
everyone thinks Asian women are sexy but
know one thing Asian men are sexy that
doesn't make any sense what do you do
all right
okay you like short hairless girly
looking dudes weirdo
well thank you for liking us you must
like kpop and [ __ ] but most people don't
know is that stereotype but we have
small things and all that everyone
things Asian women are sexy but no one
thinks Asian men are sexy that doesn't
make any sense because how do you think
you get Asian women I'm feeding your
fetish I'm in a sexy process if you have
sex with me our children they'll be very
beautiful
well then half will be great engineers
that's important too
I love how Asian women are fetish size
there was like a pop up bad as I hate do
you love Asian women I was like yeah I'm
related to three of them they're not an
object you can't tempt me their daily
annoyance one of them still has my
headphones way didn't get me her number
the Asian [ __ ] I I met this girl who
was like I love Asian men but you think
that'd be a good thing but it's more
worrisome because I'm like [ __ ] there's
a billion of us a game
hey hey I'm eating this rice sexy does
it turn you I want to respect my
ancestors I love women that's my fetish
I think they got the best genitals in
the human race definitely the top two I
think it's crazy that there are two
totally different types of people in
this world there are people that I would
never have sex with and then there are
people that I can never have sex with I
don't think I could ever have sex with a
dude because I'm into chicks you know
I've never looked at a beautiful woman I
thought yeah she's great but is there a
version of her that's bigger and hairier
and has less kindness I want that excite
me straight as [ __ ]
my friend Mike gave friends I like dude
you're so lucky you're not gay
can you imagine if most of the gender
that you were attracted to was it
attracted to back I was like mistrial
off those gays masturbate constantly I
don't understand the way my body reacts
when I see a pretty girl my body's like
a you see a pretty girl when I stare at
her for 10 minutes
show her what it feels like to be the
deer you're gonna start for her sure
your hunting skills when you go up and
talk to her why don't you start sweating
profusely
so that way she knows that if you're
caught in the jaws of a predator you can
get slippery and wet be there for her in
all their years why don't you start
stuttering uncontrollably shorter faster
Tonkin move
that'll do it I am single I have yet to
find my soulmate I begin to think maybe
it's her fault she needs to get out more
she seems like a looser better
everyone's always laying odds you know
learning how to talk to girls it's a
skill you know learn how to talk to
girls I'm like maybe you know maybe
girls should learn how to listen to
hearts why don't you want to hear about
the Federal Reserve it's so intricate
it's pretty cool
I love tinder cuz tinder is not really a
dating app it's more like a smartphone
game where if you win you get to touch
girl you can just watch like date girls
on your phone but that's kind of weird
for me cuz online on my phone that's
also where I watch porn so one minute
I'm like oh yeah she's got jizz in her
hair I love that
the next moment unlike yours demanda
what color is your hair
online dating is hard it's weird that
I'm just talking to these strangers
online I'm telling that more I talk to
them more than my parents I'm sick of it
I hate it you know I want to stop doing
it and it's not because I think girls
are bad conversationalist or not if you
listen to their whole story it makes
sense that
even if I was trying to [ __ ] dudes I
wouldn't want to chat to them online
because no one's more interesting than
their genitals feel I don't care if
you're Walt Whitman get back there
sorry I wicked I went on this date with
this one girl she was like she was like
hon divided up into a horrible car crash
and I was disfigured for the rest of my
life we just don't want to date me I was
like wow that's a really good point we
really do need to improve Highway Safety
still single I actually gave me a
[ __ ] which is cool anything else I
guess that's cool
sure yeah she would keep a steady tempo
though I was like hey you can't just
upset this [ __ ] stop drop at the base it
hurts
I came on her sheets and she was really
peeved about that she was like I have to
watch this you know but I thought she
was being negative because if she came
on my sheets I want to watch those
things for days I'll be so proud I'd
wear to the Cape go to a bar this girl
it's hard having sex because like 99% of
my sex career with solo and now now I
have to have an orgasm while someone's
breathing on me dicks all sticky with
the phone where's my office chair I'm
gonna come
this girl she was like Hans isn't it
pretty cool that my vagina is a 3d
printer I was like that's not even
accurate you your womb is a 3d printer
your vagina's a tray schematically it's
not even a very good through the printer
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors it takes nine months to print and
the whole time it's printing it's
complaining
[Applause]
that's not what I look for in a printer
I'm glad women give birth on that mend
oh I feel like a man gave birth we black
bro I've been eating so much protein and
creatine over my pregnancy this baby's
like 27 pounds ready bro it's all about
those games of the first trimester
check out ads and ultrasound I don't
understand a lot of the expressions in
America they say in prison that you
should have dropped the soap that's not
even helpful you know it should be don't
pick up the soap you could drop as
myself as you want it's a bending over
there gets it
that's not even helpful even if I don't
drop the soap I still get raped I just
have really clean hands while it
happened who are these rapists like man
I want to get that kid but he never
drops a soul
[Applause]